Êtes-vous fan d'Harry Potter ou encore de Gandalf ?
Ils ont des pouvoirs magiques qui leur permettent de faire par exemple ceci
*flamme trop stylée ajoutée au montage*
Voilà... Par contre sur le tournage c'est comme moi, c'est ridicule
Eh bien mon ami... en fusionnant les deux tu obtiens...
MIRAGE !
Arcane Warfare
Alors, alors, alors, on va aller sur un p'tit 10 vs 10
J'ai fait qu'une seule game, mon gars, une seule game
Déjà j'ai grillé y'a un perso que tout le monde prend
LUI ! Bah là il... Là il ... Personne ne l'a.
Ok, on est les rouges !
Donc j'ai des skills, c'est quoi mes skills ?
Ah , j'peux vomir avec mon bâton c'est pas mal
J'peux voler ?
Ah non.
*rires*
Damn it Lucas, teste le jeu avant d'y jouer putain.
F
Aaaaaaah, eh mais c'est trop bien !
Et mon clic droit c'est la majorette d'accord
Ok mec c'est parti on va casser des culs !
Il nous a pas vu !
Oh !
Laissez moi laissez moi laissez moi!
Oh mais j'me fais victime.
Je me fais victime, plus (+) que dans H1Z1 y'a un problème
Oh attend, premier 1v1 ou pas ?
Mais, mais pourquoi ?
Aaah, ils m'ont pris en 2 vs 1 !
Bon, les amis...
T'façon, si je perds c'est simple, c'est que ce perso il est pas ouf
Tu vois, il est pas dingue tu vois
*rires*
On va prendre elle ! La voleuse, elle est bien elle !
Bon mec,
on est les rouges, il y a 2 bleus en bas,
va falloir leur montrer qui est le patron.
J'ai mis une mine, vas-y, marche sur la mine.
Marche.
Oh, il a sauté au-dessus !
Oh, le mec est trop fort !
Tiens ! Tiens !
*bruit de lame*
Très bien.   Bon les amis, j'ai pris un perso que je sais jouer
pour essayer de faire rêver un petit peu ma communauté.
Lui, j'le connais,
c'est l'seul perso qu'j'connais
et ça, c'est très bien car il lance des sorts comme ça.
Ok, on va envoyer la gre., la gre., la gre.
et là, on se TP derrière là-bas, on se TP là-bas
Hop-la.
On envoie, un truc de zone.
*souffrance du personnage*
Le mec m'a renvoyé ma boule !
Bon moi, j'attends ici
le mec qui osera me prendre en 1 vs 1
qui représentera son peuple.
Qui vient en 1 vs 1 ?
Toi.
Oh ? Hop-là, j'me TP.
Comment je l'ai brain!
J'sais pas c'que j'ai fait en fait.
Et merde, j'ai plus de sorts, j'ai plus de sorts.
*son du jeu*
J'lui renvoie.
*bruit de bureau percuté*
Pardon !
On va changer d'serveur. Alors, c'est parti !
Il faut capturer les Demiglyphs.
J'sais pas c'que c'est, mais on va capturer les Demiglyphs.
C'est parti.
*bruits de la langue*
On le prend dans un coin,
t'es mort, t'arrête de lutter.
T'es mort putain ! Oh cette game elle me plait, ça vous a plu ?
Ce n'est que le début !
*bruit de la langue*
*son du jeu*
Hop-là ! Ohlala mais mec !
Attention, on va aider l'ami, on va aider l'allié, en difficulté !
Et *bruit de la langue*!
Oh putain, elle est chaude, attends vite la grenade !
Oh nan ! Oh putain mais la meuf, elle est,
c'est un ninja secret du japon, ça,
entrainé depuis des années par des moines.
Nan, je suis pas du tout en train de dire le scénario de Iron Fist.
Ok mec, ça manque de pen spinning ici
Voila, là ça va aller mieux.
Oh bâtard !
Et le p'tit coup !
La gre !
Le mec renvoie tout !
Jm'en vais !
*rires*
Sois pas deg !
*son du jeu*
Casse toi !
Ah c'est ma tête !
J'ai cru que c'était un pouf au début
C'est ma tête, très bien
Bon, on va pas s'mentir y'a du skill en face, mais bon c'est le temps de s'habituer
J'peux vous dire qu'après on va mieux gérer ce bâton qu'une majorette
*Bruit de la lampe qui tombe*
J'ai cassé ma lampe...
Elle là c'est elle qui m'a tué
*bruit de langue*
Oh ça a marché !
J'l'ai tué avec la gravité
Oh eh oh !
*son du jeu*
Attend mais 2 vs 1, est-ce que on peut faire des 1 vs 1 à un moment s'il vous plaît ?
*rires*
La seule fois où j'me suis vexé dans la vie j'avais cette tête et cette voix là
Et j'ai perdu tout mes amis, euh, d'un coup
Bon, on a gagné, on a gagné de l'XP
*bruits avec les mains*
Oh on est dernier !
Mec, comment on a carry
On a carry la game !
On va reprendre lui
Lui en vrai mec il défonce hein...
avec son bâton là, il me fait rêver ce perso
*bruits de langue*
DAMN ! DAMN DAMN DAMN...
lui-là... ok j'me suis soigné...
*son du jeu*
OH JE LUI AI TOUT RENVOYÉ !!!!!
*bruit de langue*
Ouuuh la première fois que j'ai gagné !
*jouissement*
Allez ! Le combat nous appelle.
*bruit de langue*
OOOOOOH !
T'es mort !
OH !
J'te traque je m'en bat les couilles !
MOI AUSSI JE PEUX VOLER !
J'TE BAISE EN L'AIR !
C'est la battle la plus épique de tout les temps
*musique épique*
*son du jeu*
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH !
DÉSOLÉ MON AMI !
*rires*
Merci. Merci beaucoup ! Tu veux quoi ? Tu veux que je te suce
la jambe ?
*bruit de langue*
Attends elle est trop forte
C'est quoi cet assassin ? Regardez-la
Trop forte
J'suis amoureux
C'est ça être amoureux ?
Oh mon dieu !
J't'aide mon amour !
*bruit de langue*
Il a pris la fuite putain
On va le suivre, on va le traquer il est où ?
Oh mon dieu mon amour !
Tu l'as trouvé !
J'te soigne !
T'es mort !
Tu peux pas lutter
Mon amour on l'a tué à deux
Ma puce viens !
Connard !
Laisse ma puce en paix !
Oh ma puce regarde ça fait trois qu'on tue
Ensemble on va faire des grandes choses
J'te suis bébé
*rires*
Ok j'dois aider mes amis !
*bruit de langue*
T'ES MORT !
Hijo de PUTA !
Attends lui faut se le faire lui
T'ES MOOOOOOORT !
Merde j'ai défoncé mon ami sans faire exprès
Voilààààà
Voilà ce qui arrive
On va bientôt gagner
Est-ce que ça m'étonne ?
Non, cette équipe est extrêmement performante
En même temps en face ils sont un petit peu trois fois moins nombreux
*rires*
Et ouais les amis être courageux c'est aussi quitter son amoureuse
Pour aller voir l'amoureuse d'en face
C'est parti
*son du jeu*
Et bah voilà !
J'sais pas si j'ai bien fait de changer d'équipe
Mais j'trouve que là on commence à avoir un petit niveau.
On commence à avoir un petit niveau, on va faire quoi.
On va retourner sur le serveur où on était au début où on s'est fait démolir
Mon pote j'peux dire que là
Ça va casser des culs
On est les violets on doit tuer les rouges
C'est parti
Et si on jouait autre chose que le vomito ?
Dégage !
♫ Tu perdras, ce combat ♫
♫ Tout donné, nain-nain-nain. ♫
Pardon, excusez-moi, j'ai ~Coïdioco en tête
Et bah, ça a marché ou pas ?
Hein ?
Et même ton arme, elle est heureuse que tu ne la tiennes plus, mon gars.
Et bien voilà les amis, c'est la fin de tous ces
petits tours de magies
comme par exemple, celui-ci, voilà.
Merde.
Pire magicien
*rires*
Ne venez jamais m'voir en spectacle si j'fais d'la magie.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu.
En tout cas, le jeu est très très cool,
ça fait plaisir, c'est vraiment un ~chevalerie v.2 avec des sorts et tout, c'est mieux foutu.
J'ai beaucoup aimé ! Je pense
streamer sur ce jeu dis donc.
Allez à très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo portez vous bien, allez ciao tout le monde...
*outro*